est ce que tu penses que giroud est ce
qu il a le potentiel pour être titulaire
à ta place en équipe de france
en gros faut c'est plus fort qu'eux on
ne confond pas la f1 et le karting et je
suis gentil
[Musique]
j'ai envie de toujours en équipe de
france depuis tout petit j'ai envie
d'être bauer depuis tout petit j'ai
envie de devenir un jour le meilleur
joueur du monde
[Musique]
techniquement il avait un potentiel
texan d'hyères ilham et jeanne il avait
d alema la place des pieds jusqu'au bout
et du palais
[Musique]
les pieds sur terre maintenant après
c'est dû à tout le travail que je fais
depuis trois ans avec les professionnels
j'ai beaucoup appris
[Musique]
c'est important pour moi la famille
c'est ça ma force entrer parce que je
termine les matches et je rentre chez
moi je vois que mes parents sont
contents
[Musique]
marine
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
et je vous dis donc c'est très sympa de
me chercher là où il emploie 1130 très
bien
[Musique]
les madrid intense escale ho kim est
lourd et il a acquis parquet par la
minorité ou contre le club
comment comment le real madrid est cité
whistle football française de tennis qui
travaillent moubarak et dallas qui
comptait sur créé au quai st cloud cela
met meoli team au cloud
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il n'est pas sélectionnable
c'est quelqu'un qui a de multiples
reprises a exprimé son mépris à l'égard
de la france qui a exactement le
comportement que les français n'admet
plus de la part de gens qui gagnent des
sommes qui sont faramineuses et qui se
comportent comme des enfants gâtés
ce sportif ça vaut pour karim benzema ça
vaut pour d'autres doit être exemplaire
ici n'est pas exemplaire
il n'a pas sa place bien sûr dans
l'équipe de france
[Musique]
je suis content pour lui parce que
souvent on voit karim comme comme le
numéro 9 de madrid il faut qu'il marque
des buts mais il fait pas que ça donc
quand ils marquent pas je suis content
parce qu'il fait faire un peut déboucher
et en même temps ce que je veux dire
c'est que sont travail de fait il a fait
quoi qu'il arrive